colombia vive su cuarta jornada de paro
nacional estamos aquí en el monumento a
los héroes de bogotá donde miles de
personas han decidido salir a las calles
a pesar de las restricciones de pandemia
las protestas están centradas
principalmente en la reforma tributaria
del gobierno de iván duque una reforma
que el propio presidente reconoció el
viernes que podría ser modificada esto
sin embargo no ha apaciguado los ánimos
de los manifestantes especialmente en
ciudades como cali donde miles de
personas llevan desde el miércoles
enfrentándose a la fuerza pública la
fiscalía asegura que 9 personas podrían
haber muerto desde el inicio del paro
nacional una cifra que organizaciones
humanitarias dicen que podría ser mucho
más altas y que podría estar relacionada
con el accionar de armas de fuego por
parte de la fuerza pública esto además
coincide con un tuit del viernes
polémico del ex presidente álvaro uribe
que pidió que los la defensa pública
pueda defenderse con armas de fuego de
los manifestantes un tuit que la red
social decidió borrar por último cabe
destacar que el ministerio de defensa ha
desplegado cerca de 4.000 efectivos
entre ejército y policía a las calles de
cali